[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and you better vacuum
yourself before you wreck yourself as
we're doing a full breakdown on the big
bad in the new stranger things season in
the latest volume we learn a lot about
his backstory and throughout this video
we're going to be going over that
talking about who he really is and also
just some of the behind the scenes info
that the creative team used to trick us
because of this there will be the
heaviest of all spoilers and i don't
want to be public enemy number one so if
you haven't watched it then turn this
video off oop already spoiled it a bit
there in that can't help myself so let's
get into the breakdown
now if squid game taught us anything it
said it was number one all along spoiler
spoiler spoiler
okay so going into this season there was
a lot of theories and rumors surrounding
wekner daca montgomery aka billy even
posted a photo of himself getting makeup
for the season and there were people
matching up the scores on his
character's arm we even had the entry in
which wekner appeared like billy to max
at one point and it seemed like
everything was finally coming up
milhouse however it was really coming at
mephisto and wekner's true story is a
lot more straightforward than bringing
him back wekner's name is based on the
dungeons and dragons character that was
once a powerful wizard however he ended
up becoming an undead creature now we
discover that he was actually the son of
victor creel a war veteran who got up to
some shady sh during the war it was war
to be fair but whether these nightmare
situations were passed on through
genetic memory or wekner simply was a
bad apple remains to be seen together
the family moved into a giant home and
though his sister was a normal and happy
child wackner didn't fit in as he
narrates his backstory to 11 he talks
about how doctors and psychiatrists
clearly picked up on his behavior
abnormal melodies and for lack of a
better word they classed him as being
broken an outcast his parents moved to
hawkins in the hopes that a change of
scenery would quote unquote cure him
however it was in this house that he
discovered a nest of black widows the
venomous spiders that eat their partners
after mating reckoner found comfort in
them and somewhat of a kinship due to
them being misunderstood solitary
creatures the mind player also shares
some similarities with the spider and
this would make sense why he'd end up
becoming the big bad's five-star general
that can have viewed the spiders as gods
on earth and with the mind player being
a god of the underworld or rather upside
down you can see why he ended up
becoming a follower of his now from the
way wekner describes the spiders you can
see why he views himself as a god too we
even get the same music used for dr
manhattan's origin story and he very
much sees himself as an omnipotent being
also zack snyder is the blueprint i like
this for like this whole scene we
actually mean it this time now he states
that they bring balance to an uneven
ecosystem and spiders of course feast on
flies and other insects also i will be
calling him wekner throughout most of
this video i know that's not originally
his name but it'll just stop the
confusion later on when he gets call
that he viewed humans as the enemies of
the spider due to our tendencies to
multiply and warp the world around us he
doesn't go all agent smith but it's
clear that he views humans as a virus
and also one that he considers
meaningless wekner says that all the
lives he observed were simply stuck in a
loop going around in circles wasting
time whilst destroying the world around
them according to him we are just
waiting to die but with us comes a very
dangerous side you very much have the
capacity to destroy the entire planet
and thus he saw wiping out the chaos
that we caused as his mission now
another interesting aspect that fechner
talks about is time and this comes from
his fascination with clocks at one point
he rants about seconds minutes hours
days months and years and how time was
invented by humans to keep everyone
confined to routines in the upside down
we discover that time is at a stand
still there and that it's exactly the
same as how it was on the day that will
buyers entered it this could show why he
wants to spend his life there as he will
remain out of the structures and
trappings of time this is showcased
early on by him rewinding the
grandfather clock he started killing
small animals a trait often showcased in
serial killers and he used their deaths
to practice his abilities during this
time he developed psychic powers which
allowed him to creep into the minds of
people as he looked into his parents
brains he realized that they had dark
secrets that they didn't present to the
world we do sort of get these touched
upon and wekner slowly started to plague
his parents minds with horrific images
which his father victor said were the
workings of a demon he showed him
visions of a burning crib and we
discovered that in the war his father
ordered the bombing of a building that
had civilians in it along with babies
however his mother figured it all out
and she apparently turned on her son
calling a doctor dr brenner to study him
avecna greatly feared this fate and
wanted to escape it so he enacted a plan
to murder his family he hoped to pin it
all on his father and after starting
with his mother he moved on to him and
his sister as we've seen with these
abilities though they take great mental
strain and when attempting to murder his
father he was nearly killed after being
overpowered put into a coma his dad was
arrested and then he woke up in the care
of dr brenner now though brenna promised
his mother that he wanted to study him
he actually had more nefarious plans and
he wanted to control his powers however
upon realizing that the boy was too
difficult to reign in he started to
duplicate becknet and began his program
that we see throughout volume four
beccano was given the code name number
one and he's where it all began now
slowly the numbers rose from two all the
way up to 11 and he put an inhibitor
device into wekner this nullified all of
his abilities and he made him an orderly
at the facility slowly he watched over
the kids unable to leave because he
could expose the secrets of what's
really going on seeing 11 as a bully
victim he slowly sunk his claws into her
and turned her against both brennan and
the rest of the subjects realizing that
she'd had a difficult upbringing too he
saw her as someone that could join him
in his quest to destroy humanity he gave
her a way to escape and said that
because of the device in his neck that
he couldn't go with her because brenna
would be able to track them both eleven
decided to help him and she tore the
chip out of his neck which allowed him
to come off the leash guards arrived and
it wasn't too long before wekner started
killing them all he also wiped out the
rest of the students and then he asked
11 to join him however she turned this
down and ended up tearing a hole into
the upside down that she tossed bechner
into in the harsh reality the lightning
there burned and warped him into the
terrifying creature that horns people's
nightmares and he gained a symbiotic
relationship with the environment we
learned that the tentacles are also very
much him and that he can cut tears into
reality beccanet is clearly pulling from
freddy krueger and not only do we get a
cameo by robert england we also get
several elm street easter eggs much like
how freddy used dreams to hurt his prey
wekner attacks his victims in their
minds which is where he murders them guy
ends up going after all the kids who now
resemble characters from wet hot
american summer now he slowly starts to
murder people one by one after first
torturing them with visions guy is
absolutely terrifying but they're always
to beat him now in the series he ends up
trying to kill max however using running
up that hill by kate bush they're able
to pull her out of his grasp and get her
to exit the upside down trailers have
shown eddie thrashing away on his guitar
potentially also being something that
he'll use in the series love is what
defeats him well latin eleven and i do
think that after she reunites with
hopper that she'll have her abilities
back to full strength nina was not only
about discovering the past but it was
also about getting her powers back once
more through taking this trip down
memory lane i think that everyone will
unite and bring it all together to
finally put an end to this bloody this
bloody guy's diabolical plans yes some
of a [ __ ] now i feel that this season
is very much gonna be about all the
characters battling him and whereas in
the past it was mainly the gang leaving
it up to 11 like the kids were past
their bedtime here i think they'll all
get involved there's also the potential
that will might too he still has quite a
connection to the upside down and
continues to draw things that we aren't
privy to it'll be interesting to see if
that comes into effect but for the
moment that's everything you need to
know about the character and his
backstory and of course love to hear
your thoughts make sure you comment
below and let me know now we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the villain
if you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers you want some
else to watch then make sure you check
out our ending explained video which
will be linked on screen right now we
had a really good time talking about
where things could be going so
definitely go head over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
peace